I don't want to spend a lot of time on
this follow-up to the Jeffrey Epstein
death suicide because there's so much to
cover but just as a brief follow-up
Donald Trump retweeted a conspiracy
theory about Jeffrey Epstein linking it
to the Clintons from a guy claiming that
Jeffrey Epstein had info on Bill Clinton
and Epstein was about to release that
info and now the guy is dead I'm showing
you a screenshot of this I'm not going
to play the video I don't think there
would be anything to gain so to speak
from playing the video Trump also
retweeted from an account called BNL
live that is literally fake news I'm
using that term the correct way I'm not
using it the way Trump uses it to
describe any news he doesn't like or
that is negative about him breaking
documents were unsealed yesterday
revealing that top Democrats including
Bill Clinton took private trips to
Jeffrey Epstein's pedophilia island the
President of the United States either
ignoring his own extensive connections
to Jeffrey Epstein or specifically to
distract from his own connections to
Jeffrey Epstein retweeting random
conspiracy theorists and fake news
websites is this the height of
desperation to distract is this merely
the height of idiocy
how are we to interpret this and of
course I already told you the
connections that Epstein had to the
Clintons he had 10 or 100 times the
connections to Trump even being on video
as I said as I played for you a couple
of weeks ago standing there with Jeffrey
Epstein evaluating the attractiveness of
young girls which ones are hot which
ones are not quite as hot so Trump
advisor and all-around terrible person
Kellyanne Conway goes on Fox News over
the weekend and good for Fox was
actually confronted about Donald Trump
retweeting this bottom-feeding pond-scum
garbage and here's how she responded why
did the president then retweet that
Clinton suggestion
I think the president just wants
everything to be investigated as you as
your reporter just revealed just the day
before there was some unsealed
information implicating some people very
high up and I'm not going to repeat
their names you already did that I'm not
saying anything beyond that and I won't
but I will say bill that there's always
this rush to we need transparency we
need accountability when it involves
fictional accusations like collusion
with Russia to swing an election this
seems to be very concrete in that
Jeffrey Epstein has done some very bad
things over a number of years and so
let's continue to investigate that I
don't think that somebody's um crimes
and the accountability for that
necessarily perishes with them we know
that you know that look the law can
allow for many different investigations
maybe there are co-conspirators it may
be there or not but again it's an active
investigation I think everybody should
be at least relieved when an attorney
general takes the action swiftly as
attorney general Barr did yesterday okay
let's see where that's kept and and he's
and let's see where it goes it's really
new this all happened in the last 24 28
hours understood and we should go slow
with this just back on the retweet
quickly it's clear what he was trying to
say wasn't it I think the president just
wants everything to be investigated and
you know that trying to connect the
president to this monster from years ago
where they're seen dancing in the video
versus other people who were actively I
suppose flying around with this monster
on his Island which was known as
pedophilia Island perhaps there's a
public interest in knowing more about
that her explanation Trump wants
everything investigated and Russia was a
hoax and well maybe there is something
there between Epstein and Bill Clinton
meanwhile step back from us for just a
second from layer one of was Epstein
more involved with Clinton or more
involved with Trump I think we know the
answer to that we know about the joint
allegations against Trump and Epstein by
a thirteen-year-old the Trump Justice
Department and William Barr are now
going to be in charge of the
investigation into Epstein so do you
think that that's going to lead to
anything implicating Trump laughable of
course it's not they control the
investigation and Kellyanne Conway
saying Oh Trump Trump wants everything
investigated well what about the
allegations against Epstein that relate
to Trump personally including mar-a-lago
including parties set up with dozens of
young girls where the people planning
the parties thought it was going to be
some kind of big party it was just for
Epstein and Trump the allegations
against Epstein and Trump by the same
thirteen-year-old girl
what about investigating that if Donald
Trump really wants everything
investigated apparently they want
everything other than Donald Trump's
many connections to Jeffrey Epstein
investigated and you know what they
controlled the Justice Department they
ultimately control the investigation
they have oversight over the Bureau of
Prisons this is how it works this is how
a swamp filling corrupt cronyism works
and more than likely we will not hear
anything else out of the administration
that connects Trump to this in any way
because they're now running the show let
me know what you think about what
happened let me know what you think
about the Trump connections let me know
what you think about what's going to
happen with investigations going forward
I'm genuinely at a loss let me know on
Twitter at the Pakman you can follow the
show on twitter at david pakman show and
while you're there please follow us on
Twitch our newest platform twitch.tv
slash David Pakman I'll be streaming
tomorrow Tuesday evening at 6:30 p.m.
Eastern Time
hope that you will join me there if you
love learning new things you probably
want to check this out the David Pakman
show today is sponsored by Skillshare
and we're giving you two entire months
of free access to Skillshare when you
click the link underneath this video
Skillshare is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking new
trician personal productivity and I'm
not even really scratching the surface I
recently took a great class on
introductory watercolour painting I'm
still not good but I am learning and you
can access the entire library of fun
easy-to-use online courses for free for
two months by using the link underneath
this video two months of learning
something that's totally new to you
something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it Pat has
taken some courses that he's found
really valuable and I think you'll love
it to get started for free by clicking
the link under this video